Today we discuss the idea of capital.
Now you may have learned in economics
class that a capital means money or
wealth. What I want to argue to you
today is that capital is really a
mechanism to extract energy from you.
Okay.
And what's important to understand is
that in a universe where consciousness
is the universe, then what energy is
ultimately is attention and focus.
Okay? So it's not enough for you to work
at something. You also have to
concentrate on it in order for capital
to extract energy from you. Okay. All
right. So with this in mind, um let's
discuss an example. All right.
Okay. So most basic example is you have
a landlord class
and they're trying to extract energy
from the peasant class.
Okay.
Now before traditionally we've
understood energy as maybe grain okay
grain
[snorts]
capital
but uh the problem with this is you're
actually not that not that extracting
that much energy from the peasant
because it's not that hard to grow grain
also grain can be stored.
Okay. So in other words, as a landlord,
your priority is not necessarily just to
um extract rent from the peasant. Your
priority is somehow to get the peasant
to focus entirely on the task at hand.
And to do that over the centuries, uh
landlords have figured out certain ways
or certain mechanisms in order to
extract the most value from the peasant
class. Okay. So let's discuss the
mechanisms. The first is that we've
transitioned from slavery
to freedom. [snorts]
Okay. If you really want to extract
value, if you really want to extract
energy and attention and focus, it's
much better to give peasants the
illusion of freedom rather than just
enslave them. Okay? So give peasants the
belief that they have control over their
lives. Another thing freedom is equity,
right? Equity.
So think of a company where I might give
you some equity and then you work a lot
harder because you think you can more
make more money. So this is a first
trick that we've learned over the c
centuries. The second trick is to make
capital
more abstract.
Okay. So, the abstraction of capital.
So, let's use an example. Okay. Grain
was uh initially capital. Uh the problem
with grain is that you only need so
much. So, as a peasant, you only want to
work as much as necessary in order to
grow grain to feed your family and maybe
a little bit more to save. But most of
the time, you just want to enjoy your
life.
But then we transition to gold, right?
[clears throat]
And gold, yeah, people are more greedy.
The bottom of gold is there only a
finite amount of it. All right? It's
hard to locate. So only a minority would
expend all their energy trying to locate
gold.
And now what we've done is we've
transitioned to the idea of money.
Okay, as I will show you, the great
innovation of the past 100 years is to
convince people that money is God.
Money is both nothing and everything.
And so you can spend your entire life
dedicated to achieving money. Okay, so
that's the second great innovation. And
the third great um technique that's
changed e economics is to understand
that if you really want people to focus
their energies, you need to create
anxiety in them. Okay, anxiety.
And how do you create anxiety? Well,
the um best way is to create the idea of
debt, right?
So, I'll lend you a million dollars
today and you enjoy it, but then you
have to spend the rest of time paying it
back. The problem with this, of course,
is that there's interest and so you can
never really pay it back, which causes
anxiety. And so the idea of debt I can
extract much more value than from you
than if you were not in debt. Okay,
that's the first tool. Second is the
idea of inequality and poverty where a
certain class of people are poor and
they'll always be poor and that
incentivizes
encourages the middle class to work even
harder.
All right. Um the third mechanism of
anxiety is wealth destruction.
What is wealth destruction? Simple war
or depression, right? When the economy
collapses, when all your wealth
vanishes. The idea here is listen, if
the peasants work really hard and they
store up a lot of grain, they have a
huge grainery, they really don't have to
work anymore, right? So as a landlord,
what do you do? we go burn down the
greenery.
All right? So, war is not just a
mechanism to expand capitalism, but it's
also a way to make people more anxious
uh because you destroy their wealth and
therefore they have to work a lot
harder. Okay? So, again, um in in
economics class, you may taught that
[clears throat] the point of capitalism
is to accumulate more capital. No, no,
no, guys. The point of capitalism is to
focus the energies of the peasants.
Okay? Because the attention, the focus
is what makes society much more
energetic. And that's the end goal. All
right? So, so if society is wealthy,
that's necessarily a good thing because
it makes people lazy and complacent. And
so the way to resolve this issue is by
constantly engaging in wars and by
having the boom buzz cycle that you
might learn in economics class, right?
So I can actually might learn that the
boom bus cycle is natural to capitalism.
It is not natural to capitalism. It is
artificial. The people in charge
um artificially
destroy economies to destroy wealth to
make the peasants work a lot harder.
Okay.
So are you guys following along? Okay.
So that's the strategy that we've
learned
um these past few centuries. And that's
why in today's society, we are the
wealthiest
society ever in human history. And yet
at the same time, we are the most
miserable. We are the most anxious and
we are the most in debt. Okay? Because
the landlord class, the capitalist, the
elite, what they figured out are three
mechanisms in which to extract as much
energy from us as possible. First is to
give give us the illusion that we have
freedom in our lives. We have the
freedom of choice. That we have equity
in society. We can vote for our leaders
when in reality it's all just an
illusion. Okay. Second is to make money
God the end all and be all both nothing
and everything. The very focus of your
life. And because money is so abstract,
you can spend your entire life trying to
achieve more and more of it yet at the
same time achieve nothing and nothing.
Okay? So think of like someone like Jack
Ma who has like more money than can he
possibly spend. And what does he want?
wants more money. Okay. And the third is
to create anxiety in society so that
people's entire existence is one of
stress and as a result people are much
more focused on work and wealth
creation. Okay? And you do that by a
constant process of wealth destruction.
All right? So, but the problem of course
is that when you push people too hard,
when it becomes so obvious you explain
people, then people will eventually
revolt against you. So, the solution
that we figured out is what we can do is
we can actually move. Okay, the landlord
class can actually move somewhere else.
And so when the anxiety becomes
overwhelming, what will happen is the
peasants will destroy each other where
and the landlord moves somewhere else to
the capital and they'll come back when
the peasant class have completely
exhausted themselves and they're willing
they're willing to rebuild society.
Okay. And this process is what rules the
world today. It is what we call
transnational capital.
In other words, the wealthy people of
the world, they have actually no loyalty
to nation or to people or to place. They
only have loyalty to their capital. And
they're willing to move to wherever they
can, wherever they have to in order to
keep their capital safe and to grow it.
And that's why a lot of people today are
moving to Dubai or Hong Kong or
Singapore. They don't care. They may not
be all that place, but they'll go
wherever
uh they need to in order to pay less
taxes, in order to avoid the social
conflict created by their policies,
okay? In order to find better investment
opportunities and that's the system is
what rules the world today. But then the
question is okay in concrete terms what
really is transnational capital what
allows transnational capital to function
to be able to move from place to place
because remember when you move from
place to place there are a lot of costs
involved for example you don't really
know anyone there and so how can you
trust the people
right and the solution that we've
developed over the centuries is the idea
of secret societies
[snorts] so What you will learn is that
secret societies and transnational
capital are essentially the same thing.
Okay. And this is the force that rules
the world today. All right. So now that
I've discussed capital, let's look at
secret societies like where they come
from and how they work. Okay. Well,
secret societies exist because the
lender class and the present class are
fundamentally different. Therefore,
um the motivations, the beliefs, the
worldview of these two classes must be
different. Okay? So, the peasants, what
do peasants want? They want to live a
simple life. They want to make some
money. They want to have a family. They
want to have some fun. They want to
believe in God. Okay? And so, for the
peasant class, we have organized
religion, whether it's Islam or
Christianity. Okay? Christianity.
Jesus, right? Jesus tells you to be a
good person. Confucious tells you to be
good to be a good person. Right? But the
land of class, they're different. They
have a responsibility. They have an
obligation to control the peasant class
and extract as much energy as possible
in order to maintain their society.
Okay? So their religious practices must
be very different. So whereas the
peasants can pray to God, the Lenor
class must fundamentally pray to Satan.
Okay. So now let's look at why the Lenor
class must pray to Satan. And this is
true for all societies throughout human
history. Before the Lenor class was
blatant about it. Okay? Now they have to
be more hypocritical, more secretive
about it. Right? So let's look at the
Leno class.
All right. So to be a learner class, to
be the lead, you have to do terrible
things. But it's actually hard to do
terrible things. All right. So let me
give an example. Let's just say I would
say to you, all right, I'm going to give
you $10 million US. What you need to do
is this. What you need to do is take a
gun and late at night go kill a random
stranger. You think, "Wow, that's a
really good deal. If I kill a random
stranger at late at night, no one's
going to know I did it and I walk away
with $10 million and you think that I
can do it. But guess what? When I
actually make you and go make you go do
it, you actually can't do it because
there are lots of
um con restrictions on your behavior.
Okay, so think of suicide. If if I gave
you $100 million and promised you um a
path to heaven, would you kill yourself?
Probably not. Okay, so suicide, killing
yourself, in many ways it's no different
from killing someone else. We can't do
it. Okay, but there actually hacks
around this. We figured out ways to make
you go kill someone
in a way that doesn't make you feel that
guilty about it. Okay. So to understand
why, I will introduce you two social
science experiments that they conducted
in America at the end of the 20th
century. Okay. The first is something
called the
um Mgrim experiment.
Um and this was done at Yale by a
psychologist named Stanley Mgrim. And
and the experiment was very simple. What
he would do is he would set up an actor.
Okay, this is an actor. Okay, what we
call confederate.
And the person will be hooked up to an
electric chair, right?
And there'll be a buzzer,
a buzzer,
which increases the voltage in that
electric chair. Okay? And there's
there's like a max and there's a min.
Okay?
And suddenly Mgrim would be here in his
lab code and he would invite a
participant, okay, who's essentially a
student to come and be an assistant.
Okay. And the assistant's job was to
press the button. And Sly Mram wanted to
know first of all, would this volunteer,
this assistant agree to shock another
human being even though he seen the
human being in pain. And second of all,
S want to see how much pain the
volunteer was willing to inflict. And it
turned out that with the idea of
authority, okay,
people are much more willing
to
let go of their inhibitions because what
you're doing is you are removing
responsibility from yourself to someone
else. I didn't do it. I was ordered to
do it. And surprisingly people are
willing to inflict a lot of pain on
other people because they are able to
remove responsibility for their
individual actions. Okay? Does that make
sense? So the point of secret society is
to for people to come together
>> and avoid taking responsibility for
their actions. How? By praying to
another god. Right? By saying we didn't
do this. We didn't go start this war. We
didn't destroy the economy. It was Satan
that told us to do it. We had a meeting
with Satan. We did the rituals. We
summon Satan. And Satan says, "For the
good of the world, you must be evil. You
must go and start this war so that we
can create paradise on earth." It wasn't
us. It was not us. It was Satan who did
this. Okay? That's the point of a secret
society to um
force yourself to believe that you have
no agency in this world and you are
controlled by Satan. Okay? Or another
god Saturn.
Right? So it's very common for the
secret side to believe in a god called
Saturn. Who is Saturn? Saturn
uh the Greek is Cronis and
Cronis is a god of time. God. Cronis is
a god of time and order and structure.
And Cronis would do things that were
unconscionable that were inhumane in
order to maintain control over the world
including in his own children because
then his children could not rebel
against him. Okay. So they pray to
Saturn to look for that divine energy in
order to maintain order and control in
the world for the good of others. Okay?
not for the good of me but for the good
of others.
It doesn't make sense. Okay, that's the
first idea I need to understand about
these societies. They always pray to a
higher god. They believe in inter
interdimensional lizard people or they
believe in Satan or they believe in
Saturn. Who cares? Okay, but it's they
don't feel as though they're in control.
They feel as if they're possessed by
demons or by extra extraterrestrials.
Okay? And why? in order to do what they
must to maintain their power and their
wealth. Okay, that's number one. Number
two is this another experiment that you
guys might have heard of, something
called the Solomon Ash experiment,
right? [snorts] And here the experiment
is 10 people in a room.
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10. Okay. And all sit
together and they're just asked to tell
me if this is a straight line or a
circle. Okay. It's that simple. Then
what happens is a volunteer is asked to
come into the room. Okay. And this
volunteer goes last and everyone around
the room goes and tells the answer.
Okay. And from 1 to 10, and these are
all confederates, okay? These are all
part of conspiracy. From 1 to 10, they
all say this is a circle. And so by the
time you get to the volunteer who's
number 11, he's like, [snorts] h,
what should I what should I say? And
often a lot of times is he'll say it's a
circle because he's trying to conform to
the group. But not only that, afterwards
when he's told that, oh, there's
actually a line he's actually convinced
he saw a circle. Okay, that's the power
of group conformity.
Okay. So two ideas authority
and conformity is what underlies the
power of ci societies
and as such
you are now because you are part of the
society you have the power to take a gun
go kill someone late at night and
collect your $10 million.
Okay? Does that make sense guys? All
right. And again, every society does
this because
often when you're part of the landlord
class, the elite, the transnational
capitalist, you have to do things
against your own hard wire wiring, okay?
Your own psychology. And that's why
secret societies exist.
All right?
[clears throat]
Now sometimes secret societies are
forced to do really bad things because
they're often in competition with each
other and in this competition it's
always question like who's more evil.
Okay. So what they figured out is this
they figure out how to structure this
the secret societies. Okay this
hierarchy
sorry hierarchy.
Okay. So these are the people at the top
the landlords
and these are basically the initiates.
Okay. The people who want to join but
they are ignorant about the two true
purpose of this society. So the question
then is how do you maintain this
hierarchy? And what they figure out is
something really really simple. All
right it's really simple human
psychology. Throughout human history
what was very common was for groups of
young men. Okay, they've been discarded
by the families because the families
don't have enough to eat. So they get
together and they form like wolf packs.
They go around and they're and what they
really want is a wife. Okay, that's what
they really want more than food. They
want a wife. So what they're forced to
do is go as a group, as a gang, go to a
village and kidnap a woman and kill the
family. Okay? And this is a very common
thing in human history.
And let's try to figure out the
psychology of what's going on. Okay? You
have like five guys. I this is this is
just this is just a fox, okay? Five
guys,
young guys, and they're going to go and
they're going to go to a village where
there's a family, okay? A husband, a
wife, and two kids. What they're going
to do, of course, is they're obviously
going to kill the husband and they're
also going to kill the two children.
Okay? And they're going to kidnap the
wife. Now, let me ask you this question.
Let's understand the psychology of this
woman. when her entire life is
destroyed. Okay. Does she A want
vengeance?
B become depressed.
C
um fall in love
with one of the guys. A B or C guys?
AB or C. Yeah. What? What? What is that?
>> A. Okay, you would you guys would think
she would want vengeance for what has
happened, but that's not what happens.
Okay, it's more likely that she becomes
depressed or she falls in love. It's
often it's often a time that she falls
in love. We call this a Stockholm
syndrome.
All right, it's a very basic human
psychology that is consistent throughout
human history, throughout all societies.
When a woman sees her entire life
collapsed like that, she now she has no
longer any stability. her reality is
destroyed and therefore she clings to
anyone
who is willing to support her even
though that person is the same person
who destroyed her life in the first
place. It's really where psychology but
it's very very true. That's also why
arranged marriages work. Okay, for
society a man a man older man is often
paired with a younger wife. She might be
like 14 or 13 but you know after a few
years they do fall in love with each
other because the woman is completely
dependent on the man. Okay. And also
that physical intimacy.
All right. So um it sounds really
depressing but this is a very basic
principle of human psychology. When
because at this at this point in history
when her reality has collapsed her soul
has left her. Okay. And now she's
basically a slave.
And what a slave does is someone who
clings to life.
All right? Does that make sense? Okay.
Now, what happens to these five guys?
Okay. A, do they feel guilty for what
they do? B, do they fight over the
woman? Or C, are they brothers forever?
The obvious answer is C, right? They're
brothers forever. Okay. So even though
they've commit this terrible terrible
act right
um it's made them more unified. Okay.
And this is a structure of secret
societies. The search of secret
societies is for the people to the very
top to commit these rituals
of torture in order to turn the
initiates into slaves. And those who are
most willing to participate in these
rituals those who are most willing to
become slaves become
um the middle people. Okay, the people
that are most trusted because now
they're slaves and that's how secret
societies work. And that's why there are
so many different degrees societies.
That's why at the very top no one knows
what they're really doing. What they're
really doing is praying to Satan, okay?
Because Satan is given the strength or
Saturn who who knows, okay? Or whatever.
um the Saturn Saturn or Satan is given
the strength in order to torture
these
uh initiates. So these initi become
their slaves for life and then these
initiates are given limitless wealth and
power because they are now completely
loyal and dependent on
uh the master. All right. All right. All
right. This sounds confusing but let's
but let's use another example. All
right. The Spartans.
Sparta. So Sparta, remember Sparta is a
war society, a militaristic society that
is intent on maintaining control over
its slaves. Okay? The helotss. And the
helots outnumber the Spartans 10 to one.
So these Spartans need to be really
cohesive as a society. They need to
fight and die for each other. So their
education system is like this. At five
or six, the child
the spartan child is taken away from the
parents. Okay. And this obviously
creates fear and anxiety.
All right. Also, what happens is the
child is in school beat up by the older
kids and this creates
trauma. All right.
Another word we use for this is interg
generational trauma because the sponsors
do this to every child intergenerational
trauma. [snorts] All right. So the kid
at this point is unsafe, insecure, his
mind is really screwed up. And then when
he's most vulnerable, maybe when he's 11
or 12, what happens now is he's paired
with an older man who's like 29 or 30.
Okay? An older man. And this older men
they become lovers. Basically what
happens is the man first of course
can commits you know sexual abuse. But
again because the child is traumatized
because the child has no bearings no
reality doesn't believe anyone in this
world loves him. Even even though man is
being abusive to him he falls in love
with a man. And as a result, the boy
will do anything that the man orders him
to do. Okay? So what happens is this man
becomes his general and he becomes a
soldier or an officer. And that's why
the Spartans are so fearless.
Okay? Because the soldiers are
completely loyal to the generals because
they were once lovers. The soldier feels
as though this general who I must obey,
he saved my life when I most needed it.
When my parents abandoned me, when I was
being beat up every day, when I felt
complete insecurity, when I was
traumatized, he came and he gave me a
home and therefore I must die for him.
Okay? And guys, guys, look, listen. This
sounds weird, but if you go to the inner
city gangs,
inner city gangs
in America or anywhere in the world,
okay, these drug cartels in Mexico, they
use the same principles as the Spartans,
okay? These young boys 13, 14, they have
no father. You put in a gang, they're
abused, and then the gang leader treats
them well. uh they might have some you
know you know sex and then these boys
are loyal to the gang leaders. Same
thing if you go to these these um child
armies in Africa. Okay. Very basic
principle that every every human
understands
if you abuse a child and then be nice to
that child that child is obedient to you
forever. This how secret societies
behave. Okay one last example.
Okay, so in history there was a very
famous secret society called the
Assassins. You may have played the video
game Assassin's Creed. Okay, why are
they called assassins? Because of the
word hashes. Hashes is a chocolate
marijuana, right? It's a hallucin.
And your mind would become blurry. You
feel as though you're in a dream and
then what would happen is I put you in a
room and you're basically like drunk.
Okay? And then these young would come
and pleasure you
and then you would wake up in your home
and you would think this was a dream.
Okay? And your match would tell you this
is what paradise is like. All right?
This is what heaven is like. If you do
what I tell you,
I guarantee you, you will go to heaven
where 10,000 virgins will pleasure you
for eternity.
Okay? And this turns these assassins
into the most dedicated killers. Again,
I keep on saying this. It's really hard
to convince someone to go kill another
person, but these assassins are willing
to do whatever it takes in order to
enter paradise.
Okay. So guys, this combination sex plus
trauma
plus
um hallucins or uh hallucin
psychedelics. Okay, these three things
psychedelics,
drugs, sex, trauma, they create the
perfect slaves.
Okay, slaves. Because now what you can
do is you can take these slaves and then
have them infiltrate other secret
societies. They become the perfect spies
because they are forever loyal to you.
Okay? They're completely emotionally
dependent on you and they will do what
it takes in order to please you. But you
have to you have to like train them from
an early age.
Okay? And this is and this is how these
societies they fight each other. They
recruit an army of young kids. They
traumatize, brutalize these kids to
train them to be spies to be killers and
then they will unleash these um kids on
other secret societies and their enemies
as well like the assassins did. Okay,
does that make sense?
Um okay, you have a question?
So like for the woman like her families
are being killed like won't he won't she
remember like who has done like who has
killed all her families but just have
relied on that
murder because he does he he's you know
>> I understand the question okay it's a
good question okay the answer is this in
psychology what you learn is that when
you're traumatized what happens to you
What happens to you? You're not there.
You're it's the word is disassociation.
Okay? You don't you're not there. You
don't remember anything because your
mind will explode or your system would
collapse if you actually remember in
detail what happened. So your mind
disassociates. You're not there. You
don't remember anything. Okay? That's
why trauma is so effective because not
only do you become obedient and
dependent on the person traumatizing you
but at the same time you actually don't
remember this association. Okay. So the
person who really controls you forget
your handler. Okay. Your handler is
someone that is at the back of your
mind. But even if you don't know that
person what happens if that person comes
before you tells you what to do you
obey. Okay, it's almost as though the
handler has programmed you and only he
knows the password. So this is what we
call programming [snorts] and this is
what they did with MK Ultra. Okay, MK
Ultra, MK Monarch. Okay, but it's a very
common thing. We've been doing this for
thousands of years in every single
society because it works and it's easy
and it's effective. Okay, right? Does
that make sense? All right. All right.
So, let's talk about the development of
transnational capital. All right. So,
there have been four distinct stages.
Let's look at them.
These four to six stages are Venice,
Dutch Republic,
England,
and what's the last one, guys?
Come on. America, right?
Okay. So these four places are special
because they are all merchant
oligarchies.
Okay, merchant oligarchies
meaning that they are controlled by
private interests.
Private interests. Now I understand that
in school you're taught that America's
democracy and English democracy and all
that. No guys, it's all nonsense. These
are olarchies. They're controlled by
private interests. They've always been
controlled by priv private interests.
They're still controlled by private
interests today. Okay? And the way that
these private interests, what they do to
maintain control over their people and
the world is through three mechanisms.
Okay? The first is banking.
Banking just means that these oligarchs
are pulling their resource together in
order to extract energy from the world.
Now the thing about banking that's very
important is that if you're able to bank
in a certain way you're able to extract
energy across time and space
right you're able to borrow money from
the future and spend it today does that
make sense okay and this will happen
with the um abstraction of capital
right so banking is basically um extract
time and space
you're extracting energy from across
time and space Okay, I'll explain more
as we go along. Okay, second is the idea
of a navy where you where you're
controlling trade. And the third is
diplomacy.
The idea of diplomacy is you don't want
to fight wars because your population is
very limited. What you want to do is
trick other people into fighting wars
for you. Okay? You want to have these
trade negotiations. So it's like spying
intelligence.
All right? And in all four, what's
really important is that if you're a
merchant oligarchy, you're actually
controlled by a secret society. Okay?
Not a king, but by a secret society.
Because otherwise, how else can these
merchants get along with each other?
Okay? So secret societies is what allows
them to work together to plan and
control their populations.
Now [snorts]
what's going to happen is this um Venice
is one of the early um oligarchies but
with each iteration it's going to
improve in power. Why? Because by the
time we get from Venice to England and
sorry to England and the Dutch Republic
we have something called the Protestant
Reformation.
Okay. So what I what I will do is
explain to you what the prostate
reformation is. But the pro reformation
radically changes
how we see ourselves and relationship
with God which makes transnational
capital much more powerful.
And then what's going to happen is by
then we hit England we go from England
to America we have the enlightenment.
Okay.
And when we hit enlightenment, what's
going to happen is by getting rid of
God, we turn money into God. And when
this happens, transnational capital
becomes all powerful. All right? So
um remember what's happening is we have
Venice then then the Dutch Republic was
more powerful than Venice because it
adopts the ideas of Pro Reformation and
then America becomes more powerful than
England because it adopts the ideas of
the enlightenment. What's happening
throughout this process is transnational
capitalist is much more abstract and
therefore much more powerful. Okay. And
therefore much more capable extracting
energy from the population. All right.
So let's go over the the procformation.
All right. [clears throat]
The Catholics and the Protestants. So
there are three major difference between
the Catholics and the Protestants.
Okay. The fir so the Cath Catholics have
three basic ideas, right? There's
orthodoxy,
there's hierarchy,
and there's just justification by works.
All right? So the idea is, hey, if you
want to go to heaven, just obey the
Catholic Church, what the priest tells
you. Don't think just do what the priest
tells you to do. Really simple, right?
Okay. But there are three problems with
all this. Okay. The first problem is
God becomes distant from you. Okay?
You're not allowed to communicate with
God. And as I keep on saying in this
class, we humans are first and foremost
religious. We want to be spiritual. We
want to have communion with God. But the
Catholic Church says no, you have to
obey us. Okay? You you have to obey our
dogma. Even though our dogma doesn't
really make much sense, okay? That if
hierarchy of course leads to corruption
where the priest can do whatever they
want
because they're in power. Okay? and they
become extremely wealthy and powerful.
And the third problem justification by
works is it leads to hypocrisy. You you
can be the worst person in the world but
hey as long as you give enough money to
the Catholic church you go to heaven
guys. Okay. All right. So that's why the
Protestants
hated the Catholic Church and so they
proposed a new system. All right. The
new system is first of all direct
access.
You don't have to go through the priest
anymore. You don't have to listen to the
dogma of the church. You can just
actually communicate with the God
directly through the Bible. Okay. Second
idea is egalitarian where there is no
longer any hierarchy. You can
communicate with God directly. Okay. And
the third idea is justification by
faith.
Okay. The problem though of course is
that these three solutions to the
Catholic problem will create more
problems. Okay. The first is that you
have direct access. So you can access
God directly. The problem is that
Christians believe in the Holy Trinity.
Okay. The Holy Trinity, right? God,
Jesus and the Holy Spirit are different
but the same. Okay? Separate but
co-equal. It makes no sense whatsoever.
And as such, if you're trying to access
yourself, you can't do it because this
force this precludes you. Okay? It is
impossible for you to insert yourself
into the story of the Holy Trinity. If
it's just Jesus, you could talk to
Jesus, but how do you talk to Jesus,
God, and Holy Spirit at the same time?
You can't do it. Okay? So, this causes
confusion. Okay. Second problem is a
idea of egalitarian. This causes just
just so much chaos, debate and chaos,
right? Because now, hey, if I want to, I
can start my own religion. I don't need
to get people to agree with me. I need
to start my own religion and have
followers follow me. Okay? So, this
causes a lot of debate within the
Protestant religion. It still happens
today where among the Protestants there
are like thousands and thousands of
different branches. Okay. The last
problem is most problematic
justification by faith. This creates
anxiety,
right? Right? Because if you don't
really know God because of the Holy
Trinity, how do you know you really
believe in God? Right? The Catholics
believe that all you do is give some
money, do some good work, don't sin, and
you go to heaven. But the Protestant
believe that no, you have to really
believe in God in order to go to heaven.
Okay. What's even worse is that another
reformer named John Calvin um he pro
proposed the idea of double
predestination
because the Catholic Church says you
know what only we can decide who goes to
heaven so if you disobey us you'll burn
in hell and John covenant to respond to
this says no no no the Catholic church
has no power over anyone because God at
the beginning of time has already
decided who will go to heaven heaven and
who go to hell. Okay, double
predestination. It's already been
decided, guys. And how do you know? If
well, the solution is through energy,
right?
If you work hard and you make a lot of
money, you become very wealthy, then you
know that God favors you. But after you
become very wealthy, what's really
important is for you to understand you
can't spend any of this money because
you can't sin. Okay? So, you can only
invest the money.
All right? And as you can understand,
the merchant oligarchies love this
because now they're taking people's
money and they're able to invest it in
any way they want. It's all going to the
bank. Okay? And this is the Dutch
Republic. This creates the Dutch
Republic, which becomes the wealthy
society
in
Europe at this time in the 17th century.
Okay.
All right. Any questions so far?
Okay. So what's going to happen though
is
by the time you go from England to
America, okay, England is also
Protestant.
The Protestant Reformation is going to
change to the Enlightenment. The
Enlightenment is there may be a God, but
God doesn't really interfere in the
universe. God lets us do whatever we
want. Okay? So it's up to us to create
our own world. So now that God has left
what happens is you need something to
replace the god right this becomes the
holy this becomes money okay money as
god and this works because if you insert
money into the protestant faith it
solves a lot of problems it solves a
problem of anxiety because how do you
know you go to heaven if you become very
wealthy.
Okay. And
everyone, how do you know you're fed by
God? Whoever is becomes the wealthiest.
Okay. So, money becomes the new religion
of America. And this is what ultimately
leads to a triumph of transnational
capitalism. Okay.
All right. Okay. So, how do we get from
the Dutch Republic to England?
Okay. The answer is very simple. The
problem is that the Dutch Republic, it
is on the continent of Europe.
Therefore, it's very easy to invade.
Now, you have a problem like how do you
keep your money safe from invaders,
okay? Because they have a lot of gold.
And so, what they will do is they will
trans they will take this money and in
1688 they will transfer most of this
money to England. Okay? So, how does
England convince the Dutch to invest in
England? Well, first thing is they make
a Dutch aristocrat, William of Orange,
the king of England. Okay.
All right. 1688, England invites William
of Orange become the king of England.
That's number one. Number two is the
Bank of England is set up in 1694.
What makes a Bank of England special is
that it is a private bank that's
guaranteed
by parliament.
Okay? Doesn't make sense, guys. What
this means is this. What what this means
is that if I make a lot of money, I keep
it. But I lose my money, the people will
ensure that I get it back. Okay? Now
what's going to happen is the Bank of
England will lend money to to England to
fight wars. Remember the Bank of England
what it is it's transnational capital.
So it's private interest but anyone can
invest it including the Dutch Republic
including guess what the Catholic
Church.
Okay. The third thing um is secret
societies.
So what's going to happen is that secret
societies are going to create these
linkages among these different
transnational capital groups in order to
allow allow them to work together. Okay.
Right. So does it make sense? And what's
really important is this system will
transfer over to America creating a
system that we have today. The bank of
England becomes Federal Reserve. Secret
societies transfer over. These are the
Freemasons. Okay. Um, all right. Does it
make sense, guys? And this is why we
have the system that we have today. The
thing that you you need to understand
about the Federal Reserve is
the Federal Reserve was set up in like
1913 or 14, I can't remember. Okay. But
the Federal Reserve, what they can do is
print money. It's a private bank. It's
private interest. They print money and
the government, how how's it going to
spend money? it borrows from the Federal
Reserve at interest. Okay? So the people
are borrowing from the bankers
and so that's why America is controlled
by private interests. Right?
Clear? And that's why transational
capital controls America and the world.
Any questions? All right. So let's go
over the PPT. Okay.
All right. So, Venice, what makes Venice
special is after Rome collapses, Roman
Roman Empire collapses, right? These
noble families, they're now
impoverished. They go to different
places. The city that becomes dominant
in the entire peninsula is actually
Venice. Why? Because it's surrounded by
Marses. So, it's hard to invade. And you
don't actually want to invade it because
it has no resources. Its only advantage
is that it's by the coast which allows
it to engage in piracy
as well as trade and diplomacy. Okay.
All right. So this is Vanish today and
as [snorts] you can see um it would be
very hard to invade.
Also remember at this time it's very
poor so no one wants to invade it.
All right, another picture. Pretty
beautiful, right?
You guys should go before um it sinks.
Okay, [laughter] if you want to go visit
Venice, do it now before it sinks. All
right, so again, a Venice, it's a
merchant oligarchy just like the Dutch
Republic, just like England, just like
America. Okay, it seems like a
democracy. They call themselves a
republic, but essentially controlled by
private interests.
Okay.
All right. So, because Venice has no
resources, it has to engage in trade and
it's going to help set up a lot of trade
networks throughout the Middle Ages. And
it's what it's going to do that's very
profitable is that it's going to import
spices from
from East Asia back to Europe. Okay? And
this is going to make Venice very very
wealthy. So, the two big cities are
Genua and Venice. Okay? Okay. And as you
can see, they are extremely energetic.
They're going to set up trade networks
throughout the world.
Um, this is a spice trade and the center
of course is in Venice and this makes
Venice the most uh um wealthy city in
Europe at some point.
Okay. Also remember what these um small
city states do that's that's very
effective is that they become parasites
on the empire. Okay. So Venice can take
its wealth and bribe imperial
bureaucrats in carinapole to give it
trade preferences. Okay.
And Venice will also set up alliances
with also the Islamic Empire as well as
the Mongols as well.
Guess who is from Venice? Marco Polo is
from Venice. Okay. Why is Marco Polo
traveling around the world? To set up
new linkages for Venice.
Okay. So, you got all these Venetians
going around the world to be spies and
to explore in order to set up new
networks for Venice because they don't
have really a choice in matter. They are
a trading power. They don't have any
resource resource on their own. So, the
people have to be very energetic. Okay.
And um while this is happening, they're
set up like these banks where the
wealthy merchants can pull their
resources to take more risks. Okay.
[snorts]
Um eventually what will happen is that
Venice will decline and the Dutch
Republic will emerge. What makes the
Dutch Republic so powerful is that it's
ruled by merchants who have now adopted
Calvinism.
Okay, remember Calvinism is the faith
that wealth is signals that you will go
to heaven. So everyone in the Dutch
Republic works really really hard. It's
a very energetic society and they can
now feed off the Spanish Empire. Okay,
the Austrian Hungary Empire, the
Hasbirds. Why? Because the Spanish
Empire, what they've done is they've
gone to South America and captured a lot
of gold and it makes their people very
lazy. Okay. So there are three ways in
which you can take advantage of that.
The first of course is piracy where your
ships just steal the gold uh as this
gold is heading back to Spain. Another
is just by providing industry for these
people. These people don't want to work
so you just sell them clothes. Okay. And
this builds up the uh industry of
France, Britain and the Dutch Republic.
The last way of course is probably
luxury goods especially spices to the
market. So because the Spanish Empire is
so wealthy, this wealth transfers to the
energy and industry of the Dutch
Republic.
[snorts]
Okay. Um and as you can see, this is
what the trade looks like. The Dutch
will set up a power company called the
Dutch East India's Company, which is
almost like a nation onto itself. It
becomes the the world's wealthiest
corporation even today. Okay. Um and the
reason why it has is a monopoly over the
spice trade from the East Indies. It has
its own army. It has it own currency. It
has it has it own government. Okay. It
can act enact its own laws in the
regions it controls.
All right. Um and as you can see the
Dutch are very energetic. So as a
comparison let's compare it to the
Spanish Empire. Okay. So at this point
in history, the Spanish Empire is the
wealthiest, most largest empire in the
world. But as you can see, the Dutch are
much more energetic. Okay, the Dutch are
much more industrious and the British
are actually much more industrious as
well. Okay, the reason why is the
Spanish are still Catholic whereas Dutch
Republic have turned into Protestants.
Okay, and this allows for the growth of
the middle class because as long as
you're willing to work hard, you you can
become wealthy. Whereas the Spanish,
it's very much a society based on
nobility and clerical privilege. Okay.
All right. So as we discussed the two
leaders of the pro reformation are
Martin Luther who proposed justification
by si by faith. Okay. Justification by
faith. You have to actually believe in
God if you want to access heaven. and
John Kelvin who proposed the idea of
double predestination which means that
God has already decided who's gone who's
who's going to hell who's going to
heaven and therefore you have to prove
it to yourself by working really hard
making a lot of money and not spending
it okay and then all this money goes to
the bank which allows for the growth of
the Dutch Republic
[snorts] all right um the process
reformation will have many major effects
on the world it will lead to something
called 30 years war and the Protestants
will fight the Catholics and this will
lead to the death of millions and
millions of people. In fact, this is the
deadliest war in Europe right before
World War I. Okay.
Um yeah, the war is deadly. It lasts for
a long time, 30 years. It will kill
millions of people.
Um because of the P reformation, the
Catholic Church is under attack. So what
they decided to do is they set they set
up a secret society basically an
intelligence agency called the Jesuits.
This is Laoya. Uh you may have heard of
Loyal University. So they just go around
the world except a lot of universities
and schools but their main mission is to
infiltrate
um Protestant societies and try to
overthrow the government and try to make
them more Catholic. Okay.
In response the so this is the um system
of the Jesuits. Okay.
In response the protest system called
the Freemasons. Okay. We'll discuss this
later on. Right. But so so throughout
history at this time there's a battle a
secret battle going on between the
Jesuits and the Freemasons. They're
using all sorts of really nefarious evil
techniques, including, as we discussed,
traumatizing young children so they
could be spies to infiltrate other
groups. Okay? Because remember, um, at
this point in history, people believe in
God. So, they're going to ask you, do
you swear to God? And you have to, okay?
And so, you have to have secret
identities if you are to pass their
test.
Okay? So one of the crucial
battlegrounds between the Jesuits and
the Freemasons, the Protestants is
England. Okay. Uh Henry VII what he will
do is he will split off from the pope
because the Henry VII like most monarchs
in in Europe they want to maintain their
independence, their autonomy. [snorts]
When he dies, um Queen Elizabeth the
first will inherit the throne. And at
this point in history, there are a lot
of Catholics who want to see overthrown.
So she launches this mass campaign to
persecute Catholics.
Um this will lead to many many battles
crisis between the Catholics and the
Protestants. Um James II is a Catholic
king and the Protestant nobility don't
don't want that. So what they will do is
they will conspire against him in 1688.
they would invite the Dutch uh
aristocrat William orange into England
to become the king and they and this
will lead to something called the
glorious revolution where now authority
passes to parliament what parliament
will do is
charge something called like bank of
England which is again it's a private
bank with a power of state they can
print money okay and this solves a huge
problem uh because Before what happened
is these private bankers would lend
money to to monarchs. The problem with
that is the monarch could die. The
monarch could be overthrown. The monarch
could lose a war. The monarch could just
decide not to pay you back. Okay? But
now if it's parliament that's boring the
money, the people always have to pay you
back. Okay? Unless England is destroyed
as a nation, your uh loan to the nation
will always be guaranteed.
And this is uh what will allow England
to become an empire. So the great
conflict uh um between England and
France of course is the Napoleonic wars
where Napoleon is about to conquer
Europe and Britain cannot have that.
Okay. Britain is is a naval power and if
Napoleon is able to establish an empire
in Europe then England won't be able to
trade with Europe. So what England will
do is finance seven wars against
Napoleon and they can do that because
they have the Bank of England which is
able to borrow unlimited amount of money
from the future as well as across space.
Okay, across time and space that's how
they're able to defeat Napoleon.
Napoleon defeated England six times. But
England didn't really care because first
of all England wasn't fighting the war.
It was just financing the wars
and England could not stop fighting the
wars because otherwise it would go
bankrupt. Okay, does that make sense?
[snorts] All right, the political wars
and this establishes of course uh the
British Empire and they can do whatever
they want now. So they take over um
India and they have something called the
East India Company. Okay. And the East
India Company is also a nation onto
itself. It it is at this time as a
company maybe the third or fourth
richest nation in the world.
And of course what they do that's very
important is they extract wealth from
India. They basically steal a lot of
wealth from India. There people estimate
that they've stolen like $45 trillion of
wealth from India. Okay. So you can see
how in 1700 before they arrival the East
India Company, India might have like a
quarter of the world GDP but over the
next 200 300 years their wealth will
plummet. Okay. The reason why is what's
going to happen is that England will
turn India into a resource colony. They
will destroy the man manufacturing base
of India, turn into an agricultural
economy and then force
India to buy British manufactured goods.
Okay. So what they will do is use India
to
uh drive their industrial revolution.
Okay. And as you can see, they're also
forcing the Indians to pay a lot more
money than their own people.
[snorts]
And so in 1913
um to 1950, the average income of
Indians don't really change that much.
Okay. But what's really important for
you to understand is this. The British
could not have done this without help
from the Indian people themselves. Okay?
So what's happening is the British for
the Bank of England, they're able to
co-op the Indian elite. Why? Because now
you're able to take your wealth and then
store it in England. Okay? Does that
make sense? Before
um you couldn't really take your wealth
anywhere. So So your interests were
aligned with the people. But now that
you're able to take this wealth and then
put it in England to be safe, your
interests are now aligned with the
British. And guess what guys, the same
strategy happened in China as well where
the Chinese local elites were helping
the British established opium trade
networks throughout the country. That's
why opium was able to spread so fast.
Okay?
And guys, the system this system is
still around today. Okay? So the British
Empire may be gone but the British
system of money laundering of um
stealing a nation's resources by coping
their elite it still exists today. Okay.
So these are all places where England
has these offshore private banks so that
the elite of Africa of Asia can take can
steal from the nation and store it in
these banks. Okay.
All right. So England has some of the
world's worst tax havens.
[snorts]
All right. So what did England do with
this money? Well, what England did was
invested in America.
At this time, America is
industrializing. And what's interesting
about America is only a few individuals
were able to monopolize entire
industries. This is Cornelius Vanderbilt
and he monopolized the rail industry.
How did he do that?
This is Andrew Carnegie who was born
poor but then he monopolized America's
steel industry. How did how did one
person do that? That's really strange,
guys.
Oh, Rockefeller. He monopolized
America's oil industry. In fact, over 6
weeks, he was able to buy out all his
competitors. Where did he get all this
money to buy out his competitors? How
did he become a monopouist? How is this
happening, guys?
JB Morgan, he monopolizes um America's
financial industry and he creat
something called the Federal Reserve,
which is which is system they still have
today where America's ruled by private
banks. Okay, how's this happening?
All
right. So these questions, how is it
possible for these individuals to
monopolize industries? Why are these
monopolies national rather than
regional? Okay. And why didn't
government make public these critical
infrastructure and region like like we
do in China, right? Oil should belong to
people. Why is belong to one person? The
reason why is
it is England that is using its wealth
from India and China to finance these
individuals. allow these individuals to
develop entire industries. Why is it
doing that? Because the Br Americans at
this history at this time in history,
they hate the British, right? The
Americans like in 1776, we found a
revolution with the British. Why would
we allow the British come back and buy
our land and our oil and our steel and
our rails, right? Therefore, they needed
people like Johnny Rockerfeller, Andrew
Carnegie to act as your agents. Okay?
Does that make sense? All right. So in
America, you're taught that these
people, Andrew Carnegie, John
Rockerfeller, they were just racks to
riches. It's because of the American
dream. It's a land of opportunity. If
you work hard, you can become a
billionaire. No, guys, that's not true.
Okay? If you bounce to society, if you
are financed by the British Empire, you
could become a billionaire. And guess
what, guys?
We have the same system today. Bill
Gates,
Mark Zuckerberg. Really strange. This
19-year-old guy drops out from Harvard
and founds Facebook. Okay. And now he's
a billionaire. How does that happen,
guys? Well, it must be the American
dream.
Oh, Chachi BT, guys.
Really strange. If you have a dream and
you just follow it, you can be a
billionaire in America.
Yeah,
yeah,
>> yeah.
>> It's all just a scam, right?
Google, it's all just a scam. Okay, what
you need to understand about these
companies is they were all founded with
US military technology that is public.
Okay, the internet, it's a US military
technology. Google, the search engines,
it's all US military technology. And
they were given to these guys for free.
Why would they do that?
Okay, again, if you think that we're
ruled by secret societies and it's
really secret societies that control the
world and they want this technology out
there to better to better surveil
people, it makes a lot more sense,
right? Because if the Pentagon said,
"Hey, we have this free computer that
you can use." You'd be like, "I'm going
to use this computer because you'll spy
on me, right?" But if Mark Zuckerberg
says, "Hey, free Facebook guys. Want to
use it?" Yeah, sure. Facebook. Yeah.
He's a dork from Harvard. Of course, he
can be trusted, right? Same same
strategy. Okay, guys. [snorts]
All right. So, 1913, these bankers met
together to set up the Federal Reserve
system
and this led to something called the
Bren and Wood system. In 1945, America
won the war and America promised the
world that the US currency backed by
gold will become
the reserve currency of the world. But
the US currency will always be backed by
gold. Therefore, nothing to worry about.
Right? Well,
in 1971, Richard Nixon says, "Screw
that." Okay? We're not back by by gold
anymore. By we're not backed by gold
anymore. You can use it. You don't you
don't have to use it, though. Okay? But
guess what?
Oil
will now be sold in go in US dollars.
Okay? This called a petro dollar. If you
want to buy oil, you have to use
dollars. Okay? And then he did something
else that was very important and
actually more important uh than uh
linking the solver to
oil. Can you guys guess what?
Oh, this.
>> Okay,
guess what?
Um, millions of Chinese working really
hard. It's all for useless US dollars,
guys. Okay.
All right. Okay, so
America was founded by Ben Franklin and
George Washington among others. They
were both members of the Freemasons.
They're both members of secret
societies. Okay, so America is really a
Freemason
um country. And how do we know? Look at
Washington DC. Okay, guess what guys,
the architecture, the city design, it's
all secret society stuff. Okay, this is
a pentagram and this is the White House,
right? This is the White House and you
can see how it's designed. This is a
cult symbolism.
[snorts]
This is another picture showing you that
this is a Freemason symbol backed by the
Pentagon. I'm sorry, the Pentagram.
Okay.
If you want to see more of the society's
occult symbolism, just look look at the
US money. All right. This is the
allseeing eye, the pyramid. It all all
the symbolism comes from Egypt, Greece,
Babylon. Okay? It's all part of the
Freemason
um system.
This is seal of the United States, the
new world order. Okay? The new world
order. We'll be discussing this next
week. Okay? But now you reach a point in
history where you got too much wealth.
People become lazy and complacent. So,
what do you do with these peasants? We
know exactly what they're going to do.
They're going to destroy the economy
like they did in 1929 and then they're
going to start
World War II. Okay, that's the that's
the goal because how the system works is
you're transational capital. You need
people to constantly focus and working.
Okay? And you do that by creating
anxiety, by destroying wealth,
by creating a cycle of constant death
and destruction.
All right, any questions? Clear guys?
All right. So, um, great. So, next class
we will discuss,
um, that's something Francis. Okay. All
right.